[Music]
[Music]
indeed a pleasure to introduce to you
this afternoon dr. Benoit Mandelbrot who
presently a sterling professor of
mathematical sciences at Yale University
and research fellow emeritus at the IBM
Thomas J Watson Research Center
personnel vault is truly a man for many
nations he was born in Warsaw Poland and
in the second decade moved to France
where he subsequently received his
doctorate for the Faculty of Sciences at
the University of Paris and he spent
most of the latter half of his life in
this country many people however
associated more closely with another
country Great Britain because he asked
to the title of one of its widely known
papers how long is the coast of Britain
here he points out that the coastline is
self-similar
under a magnification so that its
measured length will depend upon the
length of the measuring stick the short
of the stick along the coast and indeed
if it were not for the incessant waves
of tides so arbitrarily stick short
stick could be used to link that go to
infinity
his continuing pursuit of the phenomenon
of self-similarity
which he has recognized artistic
coastlines but in a wide variety of
natural systems ultimately led him to
coin a word is now familiar to nearly
everyone fractals and today his lecture
title will be fractals and science
engineering and finance roughness and
beauty this list of honorary degrees and
medals and other honours was far too
long for me to have memorized I could
read it too but this would cut deeply
into the speaking time that is
rightfully his so if you need further
evidence of the stature that he's
attained simply look at her own at the
crowd that had filled every seat ten
minutes ago
without further ado then that being to
do is professor mantle boss
it is indeed a delight to be here among
you and in particular delight to be
introduced by by Ed Lorenz
we met actually around the 64 when a
mutual friend Eric Mollick Christiansen
told me well there is another man in
doghouse not quite the euros but a bit
further and so you are you two lost
souls may find some interest in common
well Eric was very very very clear
sighted because indeed the work of of
Priscilla reigns and mine have very many
points in common even though they never
quite identically the same the same
field now the title we see on the screen
here is one which the certain sense
summarizes my my whole life I've been
writing papers for about 50 years which
is a fairly long period of time and as
time went on many people ask themselves
what was the leading sort which
permeated all my changes of interest
from one field to another and frankly my
answers were rather cumbersome it's all
lately that I realized that everything
was very simple all my life I've been
working towards what maple has become a
theory of roughness now let me describe
this fennel for this phenomena of
roughness if we think of which shapes in
our ordinary evidence are smooth well
the very few plain perhaps for a child
of amitav man a child of one spot once
upon a time in a quite a piece of water
without wind a circles well full moon
the pupil and the iris of the eye a few
more shapes like that straight lines
very few on the other side there are
shapes are absolutely without number
wherever we look we see shapes which are
very very complicated now
the history of science as I see today
after experience in many sciences
very definitely continues to be
dominated by its origin and science
began with on sensation senses the eye
the ear the feeling of hot the feeling
of heavy the feeling of rough the
feeling of sweet or sour or acid and
each of these senses except one gave
rise in due time early on actually to a
science
more precisely each went through three
stages for example in acoustics the idea
of sound was known to from time
immemorial since music always existed
and scales were known also but the
association of a sound with frequency is
the beginning of acoustics and developed
in a very strong fashion it developed
mostly by procedure which I'm going to
describe which is very important I think
acoustics did not try to represent all
sounds that's impossible it focused on
the sound of idealized strings or pipes
and did a marvelous job with them for
drums for concert halls acoustics is not
so terribly perfect but that is not a
criticism a science does not have the
perfect a science must find in one
aspect of the mass of our senses some
substantial part for which a theory can
be done and this theory must also give
insights about the cases to which it
does not stick the applying and at this
point in time much of the effort of many
scientists still is not natural enough
devoted to developing those senses which
we are described and also of course to
link them for example unified field
theories proposed to link the things are
heavy and the feeling of light light and
weight but on in all this extraordinary
effort one sensor has become totally
deprived of implementation science and
that's a sense of roughness the the
problem was very very far back being
very much one of those knots who read
all books I was very impressed to find
in Plato
one of his dialogues least her senses
and what I just said the scientists
corresponding to it and then he says
roughness is well didn't say much about
it and roughness indeed turns out to be
far more complicated than the other the
other sciences to require mathematics
which was a market higher markedly
higher level of complication on end of
difficulty so what my my whole life has
aimed at was to find the regularities in
variances in Sciences all is only study
with variances in variances in our
experience of roughness which might
apply throughout and might provide tools
for attacking roughness in all its
aspects so when when I say that fractals
which is the world that corn for a
certain kind of orderly roughness they
occur in mathematics I will give you at
least one example the sciences I'll give
you few examples in passing engineering
in finance I'll spend some time in
finance
now sometimes one wonders why all these
days topics are brought together they
are not brought together for any
fundamental reason except that they all
exemplify once again this very simple
environmental issue the question of
roughness so as I see on first line
fractals are simple complex and
open-ended what I mean by that if one
begins to define fractals without the
kind of cloud of sophistication regular
and mathematical elusiveness which was
given to them for quite a while when
they were purely part of mathematics if
one forgets about these complications
actually simple in fact children to a
taught the ideas very very early on but
these very simple rules create
extraordinary complex reality and very
rapidly as I will show you shortly
and it's open-ended in a sense that one
very rapidly goes to problems of such
extraordinary difficulty that the best
minds are struggling to to cover them
now
everybody knows me for pictures and for
some pictures who has quite the
glamorous I'm very very happy about them
I'm delighted that an instrument like
the computer which at that time was
devoted entirely to arithmetic
operations in the light could be have
been tamed for the purpose so different
from its original purpose but my
experience is that if I start throwing
pictures I will never end
the great fun for you for me but it's
out of place so I will
I was simply not not dwell on them I
will just show you this one
well let's now get from my point
what is roughness and how to how to
handle it
well it's very appropriate that this
auditorium is a building of Earth
Sciences because nurse scientists and by
the Miss wick me trough gave me this
picture
he told me that when he trust geology to
his students he is very careful to tell
them at every given time always put an
amount of scale because if you don't put
them in the scale you'll forget how big
the thing was after Russia photographed
so you put yourself a camera cap or
something in it and then you remember
how big it is otherwise you forget you
confuse a pile of rocks and a mountain
well here is example indeed of this
confusion this was cheating is very easy
to cheat because indeed this type of
terrain is the same at all scales now to
be a same at all scales is at this level
an element of purely fault floor and I
will hasten to go ahead and speak of
Finance since I spent very many meters
of my life both in the 60s and again
recently studying financial prices in
finance there is also a piece of
folklore which says that if you put
price a price graph somewhere be careful
to put a scale of time because otherwise
one would not know whether the price
changes or prices have every minute
every second
well that's recent already they are
every year it's all the same goes up
north wing zigzags and so on this is for
florrum and I'm not on a shame
are embarrassed to speak of folklore
because in a field like optics folklore
has been how to say taken advantage of
long long time ago in the fields which
I'm interested in in fact very often
very little was known therefore folklore
is very very essential especially if the
fourth law can be can be how to say
change modified to fit other purposes
now what is this Walter about primarily
now this edible vegetable indicates its
structure it is cauliflower obviously
its most striking feature as everyone
knows that is that one takes a florid as
opposed to whole cauliflower and drops
everything else the florid looks exactly
like a small cauliflower and then I do
it again again several times well it's
very interesting that this this feature
was known to everyone but I found very
little mention of it until my work
perhaps the the cauliflowers are very
interesting they look not from side the
very top and there are all kinds of
Fibonacci series all kinds of structures
in them these attract the very much
attention but I'm not interested here in
in how to say precise description of the
arrangement of Flores on something much
much more important which is the
roughness certainly surface of this this
vegetables very rough is thereof in a
very excessive fashion that is highest
for the hierarchy a big thing is made of
parts identical the big thing and so on
and so on
the parts are well defined now the world
in general is not that simple
and in general the this idea of large
and small-scale parts is of course all
mixed up and confuse them now this
marvelous graphic is due to my friend
Richard was to implement a model of
mountains that I put forward in the way
back in the early seventies before
computer was able to do anything of this
sort
now in it it is not a picture photograph
it is not it is not a painting it is the
implementation of a mathematical idea
and the mathematical idea is so abstract
and so how to say
devoid of substance that was very much
attacked on his account the idea is
simply that there is an invariance
between the roughness of mountains in
big small and in very small scales now
again it was not something which I had
to say quote unquote
invented explorers of the mountains
whimper who climbed the one Matterhorn
at least was the first man recorded a
slang Matterhorn wrote about his his
rambles in the Alps that a small part of
the of the landscape is same as a big
part and he had all kinds of
philosophical consequences from it but
it was certain not taken seriously so
what I did here it was just to embody
this idea of wisdom this wisdom of
folklore and replaced by invariance now
one knows these variances which occur in
in activity see quantum mechanics and so
on hidden variances that those of
dilation and reduction if you dilated
and reduce it appropriately
it doesn't change well we can go on
forever and but I would like first of
all to give an idea of the natural
problem and just how it how always past
the the idea of fatality I flashed on
the world that coined in 1975 the idea
of last allottee did not exist before
but an intuition of fatality and in fact
examples of use of rest ality go back
absolutely to time immemorial this
picture here is at a village in Tanzania
of a nation which I don't think lives
there it's a ruin but if one looks at
this that feels carefully one looks
mostly for a top which is less nice
photographer but more telling one
realizes that's made entirely in a
hardcore fashion there is a whole
village here that this distinguish here
which is the harem of the king then the
King's house and so on everything is on
the same pattern but more or less big
humanity has always known of that but
this was decorative device and the
the Dakar device was known again to
every country I chose Africa I might
have chosen just as well temples in many
from parts of the world
now we get to to a point or two points
rather to the right of this picture you
see the celebrated face of war of Dali I
don't think that in you about returns to
the left you see this abstraction which
has a long history it is actually I saw
it for I first discovered myself
discovered quote unquote invented world
whole world and then I realized that a
man named shape is he had written a
paper about it and I need a name a call
shabiha gasket to make it sort of nice
and it is had become very important
shape in physics you see exactly how
it's built
I don't know I have to tell you take a
triangle you take away small triangles
now the the most astounding factory that
you go to Sistine Chapel you find
approximations of it on the pavement if
you go to churches you find these kind
of structures all the time it has been
all along a very long in decorative
design
so to summarize and fractals have on the
one hand a very very old history and
then this shape the triangle was was
drawn first around 1900 then was a
period in which mathematicians started
distilling them did they know about the
uses of fractals in the decoration I
don't know there is no record of the
talent
however tantor who was one of the great
among them did write the record in
writing of his thinking and he certainly
wrote to his friend Dedekind repeatedly
that we mathematician are of a divine
race and we can devise shapes that
nature does not know so at least one of
them thought they were inventing
something in fact they're not they were
putting in a very very precise form some
structures which humanity has been
always familiar with and so then the
question arises what if you want to
begin a science you certainly must need
numbers for the for it and the
astounding finding was the case at least
15 years ago that whereas of course
loudness had been measured very well
which has measured very well by a
frequency and the same thing for for
visual impressions weight has been
measured temperature had been measured
that was actually invention in history
by Galileo
there was no measurement of roughness
and I wrote in mid-eighties nautical
with some metallurgist friend about
roughness and he showed me after after
many examples that in the literature of
broken metals of fractures or metals the
all kinds of measurements of roughness
are very very imperfect and very very
unsatisfactory well so I introduced in
science a notion which which I call
fractal dimension which I takes many
shapes I'm going to go very quickly
through it it is a simplification of
something which had been used before
used only in mathematical esoterica by
hausdorff and that simplification that
I'd how's the dimension is impossible to
defeat in science it has no there's no
way to measure it because operations it
embodies the other dimensions are indeed
immeasurable and in fact something very
interesting happened you will see these
dimensions come in fractions and after
several years of working with them in
fact doing nothing else except using
them in one context or another I I
didn't see I taught myself about about
about roughness because everybody I
think not about that I taught myself a
correspondence between roughness and and
this number an anecdote at one time a
friend came to visit me at then two
programmers to show us a beautiful new
construction and he asked me to guess
dimension my two programmers who had no
experience of it once in 1.2 and Yoshie
1.8 just out of the hats and I said this
a little bit short of 1.5 it was 1.48
and then I'll come back to an example of
what well guess dimensions for tourism
because of being attuned to it again I
don't think that I have a skill which is
unique I have established myself a
correspondence between this number now
how does number come
it starts with a very very trivial
property of dimension ordinary cases you
divide a string into n parts or a square
hand 15m parts in each case dimension is
the ratio of log of n divided by log 1
over R whenever I publish that a
scientific journal and idiot editor tell
me which base of course doesn't matter
because the ratio now you are putting
the the usual usual shapes you take em
an interval you replaced by the zigzag
well for parts and you repeat again
again well here if you take the log n
over log 1 over R you get 1.26 etc in
the middle part you get 1.5 exactly in
the right path you may we get point to
2.0 I'm not going to go into details of
it it would take forever
however this and related quantities have
been totally tamed to measure that we
measured sometimes with exquisite
precision in one object which I to which
my current latest paper is devoted the
dimension is 1.71 with some uncertainty
about the next decimal it's well
uncertain not much but it's astounding
that the notion which is abstract when
properly generalized and so on becomes
so completely measurable and so let me
now bring this matter of for tourism now
this picture is my book I forgot which
page I was on I was very much in this
brown motion Brownian motion is one of
the center of probability theory of
course it's a process which was defined
by Norbert Wiener and 20s and was his
greatest claim to fame for a long time
it's a drunkards walk and you see this
black black line goes around it so I was
drawing these things all the time and in
a certain sense I was fishing
well maybe fishing well I'm very strong
impression that my collision friends
just underestimate the power of their
eye well there's something else to it
people are more or less good
the eye I mean it's very clear
scientists are good mostly on exams
which measure ability to do algebra fast
and correctly so it's not necessarily
case that scientists have very good eye
at least not mathematics and physics
certainly in other fields the answer is
yes but I do have a great dependence on
my eye and I was playing and playing
playing and then decided that the whole
this thing was a bit too diffuse and the
Brawn emotion were starting here and
going around around around ending here
so everything was looking for was
invisible everything else looking at had
been known before
so I decided first of all to have the
snake by this tail by having ocean
motion come back to where I started
and that's again idea of Norbert Wiener
it's called a brown region and then I
decided to color it color doesn't mean
that put fancy colorful things like on
these mountains on the Mandelbrot set
it's just very simply to make a
different beam inside and outside so all
the points which could be gotten from
outside on are white all the points
which are not accessible I made are put
in in gray when I saw this picture first
my screen I tell you I've been
speechless the picture screamed at me I
am an island a very complicated island
now as ed has said the whole long across
of Britain and you can replace any
island as you wish in it is a very basic
issue and the length isn't like
irrelevant because it depends upon how
you measure it the roughness is measured
by dimension and so I've seen many
islands real ones and and and and fake
ones and this one was very very
irregular so my first reaction was about
the most difficult islands I've seen
were foresters 1.5 and got beyond 4/3
was a magic number for third world was
the islands I had I was very much
pleased with that being sort of
irregular then I measured it because my
can measure it and the
so was that the dimension was one point
three three three three six well this is
a humongous simulation so you can get
these things very accurately it was for
tourism now the most extraordinary thing
about that is that it begins to be
attuned to it you look in these kind of
contours for all kinds of shapes and
some people claim that the left part of
it is pain which have been sort of made
bigger that England of course had been
vanished before different Island
Scandinavia was there a bit out of work
and people begin to see actual
geographical features and very easily
and that's sort of almost o matic you
always do curves of this dimension and
you find it well for thirds was for a
long time a conjecture for 18 years then
a friend of mine build up the 20 plot he
gave a demonstration as a 4/3 which was
very beautiful but not rigorous he calls
that exact but not rigorous it uses all
techniques of physics which are probably
correct but are not certified as such
and then shortly afterwards SRAM Lawler
and and the vendor proved it now what is
interesting here is not that the theorem
was proven actually proof take several
hundred pages is extremely difficult it
the techniques of every kind is
something overwhelming thing the
interesting thing was the extraordinary
short path between a childishly simple
thing namely a drunkard a drunkard going
around and then a question which is very
difficult but for 20 years baffled
baffled the most brilliant among my
friends and all the topic of great
despair first of all they said I'm going
to do overnight then next week next next
month next year finally to the
Millennium
well didn't take a millennium but it had
to wait on the next millennium it's very
often the case and I think that actually
it is representative of a theorem or
what I say about roughness that
roughness is have not been explored
systematically for itself
I mean I made
some devotion to it but was not there
for it is not a case in which simple
problems have been solved long ago and
only difficult ones remains simple to
state I mean it's also a field a field
which is not very old
so there very few cases in which a prime
arose out of previous problem problem is
the question mathematical questions
arise out of things which are very very
common and I will tell you at the end
more about my very great commitment now
to education and one of the aspects
education is to him is to realize that
even adolescence sometimes the small
children high junior high and so on are
very comfortable with the concept of
that describe roughness the concept of
self-similarity concept of algorism i
mean if if no affiliation is added they
understand very well and then when when
they see that by a little manipulation
from these very very simple things when
gages very complicate matters I think
that we make them understand to at least
some extent this notion of extraordinary
fruitfulness of science entry in in
creating primes as it develops and well
it's a course at Yale which I expressed
very hard with micro framers tell you
more about that it's the last line token
of the value of the eyes recently turned
to pure mathematics expression of that
is that this neutral about that in a
French tradition of setting American and
the illustrator felt obliged to mark the
boundary of the subject the whole point
that the boundary was not didn't have
been marked the boundary was visible
without the impact you didn't have to
mark it well the the all that cries out
for for simpler proofs and I'm going to
to to go further the critical
application clusters I would not go into
into the case of the oddities but the
general idea is is very close to what
the structural magnet isn't a magnet is
made of lead magnets going up or down
and there are critical percolation
clusters
complicated shapes and they too have
boundaries of dimensions 4/3 and also
7/4 because depending what you look at
you get either 4/3 or third fourth it
was an object of great fascination
measured after I I brought out 4/3 and
again people on ship did something about
it and and Stas Smirnoff proved it
earlier this year it's a it's a whole
field which as a reason which no is
completely independent independent of
the eye of course but which would not
have arisen without the eye and I really
think that's very important from
viewpoint of an understanding of science
to to realize that the what has happened
the reason why the I went out of of the
hard sciences was not hots a decision by
some committee to neglect it it was
observation that last time time went on
a new questions did not come from the I
new questions came from all questions
also the fact that once those Sciences
were established again
the simplest things were very rapidly
done and then that more complicated
things came from simpler things in the
field itself but in in the case of the
prices of the roughness and of the
topics are discussed all my life she's
very different are still very very close
to to the initial basic issues and
therefore the I had been absolutely
indispensable the I and sometimes even
even hearing in many cases I have
transformed some signals into noises
which are audible and discovered in so
doing that phenomena which previous
analysis had declared to be identical
very fact very very different this
sounds very different the now I would
like to just make one rapid step back to
the Mandelbrot set which I didn't want
to spend all my time on in fact almost
no time the when I became fascinated by
the subject discovered and described it
in in around twenty nine eighty I
started with the definition which is
different from the one which everybody
now uses and it turned out that very
difficult to
to do numerically on the computer at
that time very very clumsy and so I
changed definition which is a process
map additions like but in this case I'll
show you definition thinking are two
definitions identical and the second
definition is one everybody knows is
very easy to put a program and all these
incredible riches came out pouring but
and observations made on the pictures
became mathematical conjectures and the
modified proven great success but the
initial idea that the two definitions
are identical well one set is the
closure of the other that assumption
conjecture whatever is still not proven
we use that and brand brownian cluster
in this course at Yale on Infractions
phenomena titian and also in workshops
for high school teachers because they
there is nothing there which has to be
left on explain everything is then we'll
explain in great detail and they
understand very well the nature of some
problems which otherwise would not be
understood now let me change topic
substantially but not so brutally
because it what I'm going to say applies
not only to prices but also to many
noises many phenomena in nature in many
fields but this corresponds to one of my
earliest fascinations with with price
financial crisis in the early sixties
and then topic which I very much devote
very big part of my life to at the press
at present now prices of course go up
and down that was not to everybody and
all kinds of nice maximum is about it in
1900 an incredible genius local problem
his name was liberally nobody notice him
he had a very miserable life but he
wrote a 900 miles believe it or not
called the seer speculation speculation
meant a speculation on the stock market
or bond market and the heater used for
the first time in
loose and incomplete fashion the Bryan
motion which Weiner later made into a
central mathematical topic and which
means in between Einstein and others
made the central physical topic now the
idea of bascially was more or less that
prices vary at random you can't predict
them you toss a coin if it's heads you
price blow up its tails price goes down
and you go on and on and on well you can
approximate that by sequence of
independent variables and you sit on top
very clearly the sequence of independent
Ossian variables which are the
increments of Brownian motion it's also
quite noisy realistic all white noises
we call gaussian Gaussian white noise it
makes a very big difference I'm going to
argue in a second now a much later a
whole theory of stock market occurred on
the basis that this model bascially is
indeed representation of reality and the
very the size of these increments of
price the this size is what's called
volatility the model assumes constant
volatility and indeed if once you're
seen a little piece of this line on top
you have seen them all don't very much
alike and if you average it you take the
averages moving averages this whole
thing goes to 0 very very quickly
now look immediately at the bottom five
lines skipped or come back to them later
at least one of them is a real price
serious price changes or at least one of
them is illustration of my current
forgery which is called the multi
fractional model of price variation now
I'm sure that many many people here are
such great geniuses that we are going to
guess meat which is which but you are
exceptional most people can do it
because all these all these phenomena
have a very strange fatalistic that a
very big Peaks all the time and the
peaks don't arise by themselves the rise
in the middle of periods of rate
volatility then the peers of a very low
volatility the appearance of reduce oil
changes volatility
as you try to grab it in these sequences
either the fake or the real ones is
something very very very elusive in fact
it's impossible to be impossible to
grasp and so how are we going to
represent those phenomena and I will put
this this example in particular because
it puts in contrast very very sharply
the approach to roughness which which is
had been used by I think most authors
before fractals and the approach to
roughness which I've been advocating and
I would like to emphasize differences
without going into non calculations then
the approach was more people have been
advocating is if a constant volatility
phenomenon doesn't work then replace it
by something which is a variable
relativity and if that doesn't work been
replaced by something at discontinuities
or jumps well this is very much the
spirit of the celebrated model of the
motion of planets due to polymers in the
Ptolemaic model the planets grow around
circles and the Epis a epicycle cycles
which are and then the epicycles plants
growing on circles which centre of which
grows another circle and then in
addition one must assume that the center
of the basic circle is not identical to
the centre of the universe
in fact the C factors everybody knows
that how kepler replaced that by a
different formula which later Newton
transformed by explaining it through
gravitation but the main fact is that
that two approaches to to this
phenomenon either that the prices which
are in the lower part are just other
examples of something or something
complicated and pleasant which are just
combinations of the simple all that
there is something radically new which
involved now tell you about how
radically new this
has to be many of these these very big
Peaks you see on the five the lower
lines exceed well something which is
defined a standard deviation actually I
don't know how to exactly measure but
sort of ten times bigger than the
standard deviation of the most examples
that called ten Sigma events now ten
Sigma events in the Gaussian process
Gaussian indepent process on top the
probability will be 1 million millions
and millions and millions the inverse of
a picados number it's a very small
number if that were the case these
things will never happen but as you see
here to happen all the time so it's not
a matter of adding a little bit of large
values because one good situation in
which the large values dominate
everything very strongly as a matter of
fact I'm going to go a bit illogically
to make make a point early on the
central aspect of statistical physics
that is Roselyn AMEX is that the big
system evolves in a certain way namely
entropy increases with probability one
the probability zero entropy is going to
decrease but the events of probability
zero are totally totally negligible the
events which count are those of
probability 1 a average of course
converging everything the past the
future independent all kinds of
beautiful theorems apply but if you know
to to to financial prices it's again
part of folklore if you look at last ten
years and the wonder assuming that
somebody with miraculous powers of of
seeing the dark some devil would pick
the days that matter you realize that
that the desert matter over just ten
days out of last year's very few days
mattered and the great fortunes were
made in very few days great ruins
happened very few days so one gets
ultimately decision which is very very
unsettling that is in this context only
the very few rare events
account overwhelmingly and the rest
doesn't count hard thoughts hardly at
all
it's a way in which context which one
must review review ones and ones ones
the intuition very strongly but
reviewing not reviewing it's best not
abandon solid ground and abandoned the
principle of modeling the primary
principle of modeling which is that of
invariance it becomes almost a joke Isis
before to others to extend some
scientists and one of them emphasizes
that the basic three society's variance
you finds the right invariance and in
fundamental physics you look for all
kinds of new invariant system and the
lucky ones or the perspective equals
ones are and the ones who find better
theories in this case the matter was to
find the right invariance and so I'm
giving you them the key the the
forgeries which I'm which I introduced
in among these these lines were not
chosen by taking the line on top and
adding this adding diet adding listening
that until the thing looks more or less
reasonable it can be done but I don't do
this way the the key is to find right
invariance and lo and behold the right
invariance gives this result now let me
identic step back up because it's a
lesson which no no not only applies to
this financial crisis but to many other
phenomena believe it or not but the five
bottom lines are all white noises I
repeat they have a spectrum which is
constant there is no correlation but I
believe it is full of very interesting
structures having a white noise to be so
interesting I'm used to white noise like
on top which is boring which is like
you've seen one red would have seen them
all like former President Reagan said
the bottom everything is different well
the fact is the bottom five lines are
not Gaussian therefore not being if not
Gaussian whiteness does not imply
boredom whiteness implies a very very
often a very rough ride them
now the the second ID so the two of them
a tool of science namely the spectrum
which had been marvelous is not
applicable this context it doesn't work
I mean again Wiener was very clear in
when he described spectral analysis
early early on as you realize winner one
of my intellectual heroes and the he
want his rabbit the conditional which
spectra are good but these conditions
are not satisfied for this for this data
now is that a new finding by big
Mandelbrot that these are white
by no means I remember when spectrum B
team became usable after the fast
Fourier transform was discovered
rediscovered rediscovered actually
everybody went on to specialize
everything in sight and prices were
sterilized the Eternity wide price
changes and the result was absolute
absolute horror how can I be if it's
white should be like the on top now
every book of per mathematic says that
independence and orthogonality are the
same for Gaussian processes
orthogonality means a wide spectrum in
this case but nobody paid attention to
it because the examples given when they
are different are very made-up examples
these are not made of these examples the
examples made by culture in so far as
the stock market is not part of nature
therefore as part of culture and or made
by me which is also cultural but so you
can have structures in this fashion now
the only thing is the habit came in in
from thermodynamics that if you take a
big enough system then fluctuation does
not matter in fact the whole single
proving the larger bigger and bigger
system ultimately fluctuations both
matter and the average out but look at
the single left it is it is not quite
the same thing all right it is squares
of it and there's some hanky-panky to it
but it's about roughly speaking
variation of prices over a century if
this these real things the right were
just fleeting defects which averaged out
then the over or a century have been
very very smooth indeed and certainly
not smooth at all so we did a phenomena
in which averaging does not really make
any simpler and that's again the
signature of a self of an invariant
processes the same a small scale a big
scale self similarity or variants
thereof enter into this game and so let
you know it so the the models I'm going
to say a few more words about that most
fractal models but the second layer on
top was my first model of prices it I
called meso fractal now it's a new term
because I need these terms for various
reasons at that time I was so focused on
large values that I've neglected the
dependence between prices
the bottom line is bottom lines show you
the price of enormous dependence I mean
that's why people can give you a
prediction actually possible and well
anyone from another but that's not
different issue of here but the the
second line was independence have these
very long Peaks and that took care of
one other problems which is the
long-term dependence the long tails the
large values then I had another way the
second line take care of long-term
dependence but only multifractal took
care of both it's interesting that multi
fractions but the fact allottee is a
notion which I introduced in about the
time I met Ed Laurence I'm at first a
little bit later to explain the nature
of of dissipation of turbulence not
explain them so I take it back of
describe it explained is a big word
describe because it's a topic in which
truly the natural tools borrowed from
other successful Sciences have been
quite unsuccessful now let me explain to
you how here this matter of self self
sameness which is no longer search
similarity but self affinity enters
around so this is not a model of price
change
it's a cartoon what's the cartoon a
cartoon is something which has
which has recognizably same features but
which is simpler to draw and to behold
so on top you have a straight line a
trend which the price changed from
beginning to end I was told by all means
it must not be going up so it's going up
and then there is this this variation of
this price which is second line which I
call generator goes up up down up and to
simplify it I make it symmetric then for
each of next stages I do is to take this
generator and squeeze it
but you see my squeeze it in different
ratios this way in that way if the ratio
of squeezing were the same both
direction you would deal with a
similarity and the Signum is
self-similar the switch at different
rate rate so this one this way it is an
affinity mathematically therefore these
things are self a fine and if you goes
down you turn the thing back it was
again again now after a while you get
this jagged curve which has certain
amount of boring regularity so you
inject the minimum amount of randomness
and to the song you simply at least at
each before you do you introduce
generator you choose at random between
see possibilities down up up up down up
or up up down a very easy to simulate
and then here is what you get
was different on top with the values I
you saw in previous picture you get the
sequence which is more or less what
Ashley was saying more or less what the
conventional so-called feared market
supposes coin-tossing or a variant there
are then what you do is to come back to
precinct you move the top the stop point
a little bit to left so you just you
have one parameter here you see one one
point parameter the point parameter is
the first break determines the generator
and some as you do it you realize that
suddenly this thing becomes a memory
regular now this order is to it it is
not an incredible accumulation of cycles
epicycles not central circle cetera
cetera
it's simply cell affinity this these
curves are increments
settling process which is certifying the
construction because you do it by this
recursive process which has the minimum
amount of of randomness name is
shuffling and at the end you get
something which is none of the realistic
for stock market because it seldom
happens that you have experience but
almost nothing happens if you enter in
further you got even further so you can
go beyond what you observe stock market
now I don't see the model I just say
that it's a case in which the first
investment gives a high yield and I have
been many sciences and I'm also history
not solid records of many early days of
many many successful theories in science
and there is a one theme which runs
through them which is that the first
stage was awfully simple and it gave
interesting results then well bells and
whistles were added but only gradually
and that those theories which began by
design which was full of bells and
whistles to make it look right never
take off they just overburdened to begin
with them now I don't say this one is
going to is going to take off it's very
widely respected very widely criticized
is very widely hated it's very widely
etc etc but it the point is that it
provides what I think was the answer in
this context to have an extremely short
no bells no whistles path between
folklore and a quantitative measurable
realistic and also realistic
representation of data but now here is
something which is very disquieting so
you see on top of these things zigzag is
not the same before but again you just
take the exact and you do it recursively
by changing the sequence each time and
so these eight sequences of increments
are identical from viewpoint a process
generates them and here we get into one
of the most
constant and the most in fact
perturbing features of fractal phenomena
and the perhaps how I would I would
first I would first comment on that
if you apply to these eight and eight
processes the usual techniques which
applied to two random very very
phenomenon you find that they're all
different the variance is different the
correlation is different well in this
case not even white because I didn't
make sure the white it's very
complicated if you apply the right
techniques which are techniques of
multifractal analysis which developed
for the purpose of measuring roughness
then all these eight are the same let me
come back now to this matter of the
author of metals I mentioned earlier so
dumped a soldier who's metallurgist was
getting from whoever national your
standards or maybe it's already
different names sort of finger shaped
pieces of metal in fact the team in
large number so did the National Bureau
took a piece of metal and had an
extraordinary careful treatment with the
expensive piece of metal they are very
carefully treated at a constant
temperature or for a long time
so D homogeneous and then they are cut
into five pieces and sent to different
laboratories order them
we caught them bang bang bang bang we
measured the roughness as as the book of
metallurgy said it should be done and
that measurement was low and behold
exactly the same as the measurement
advocate in the books of Finance that is
ute approximate this method by a
straight line or by playing or whatever
and took at the root-mean-square
deviation from that level and you
assumed root mean square deviation is a
measure of non flatness well it is a
measure of not non flatness
but the horrible fact was that we had
five samples which the National Bureau
standards guaranteed to be identical and
the the measures of roughness were all
over the all over the landscape so
didn't measure anything if you measure
the root
squaring these things get results for a
completely all over landscape these
things are totally different
the suggest next round level very
variability however is then measured for
the for the for the the these fractures
when you measured the flatten dimension
not quite as simple as what I wrote to
you but the next simplest algorithm
which makes it measurable we found in
all cases lo and behold hold your breath
for surgeon
well not quite 4/3 forces for lines and
it's a normal dimensional line is one
curve so two plus one-third and for
surfaces two plus one-third some the and
then people redid the experimental very
much longer samples and they found that
indeed the 4/3 holds over five orders of
magnitude that is here is the case of
roughness in the most if you forgive me
the roughest form the roughness of
broken piece of metal by looking at the
wrong measurements you get values all
over landscapes landscape by looking at
the right measurement you find the
certain values and measured over five or
more order of magnitude the heat
treatment only changes the cross overs
at the end and makes this range bigger
or smaller but the precision of this of
that is absolutely incredible it's also
true for for glasses is true for variety
of Extron the different surfaces rough
surfaces have this property of plus
one-third
now I view that as being first of all an
example of a mixture of nature reduced
to a manageable concise and clean
conjecture it is not a completely
statement of structural metals a simple
statement that thing is for surgeon and
it is of course the greatest clear
successor latest
token or successor for a model which say
that this way of measuring it now after
having given you this example with
construction I want to describe this
in physics it's very important once you
have a certain model to change some some
characteristics temperature and
something else anti phase diagram in
which one sees how the property is a
system vary and so there are three ways
of showing it for the symmetric again
going back to prices for symmetrically
generators and and well let me let me
show this and I come back to the
previous thing this this is them on the
left on the right a test which tests
whether price changes are indeed unit
followed the multi-platinum model here
the price in the question is is the
exchange rate between the dollar and
Deutschmark which had the advantage of
being rather clean finite samples since
on January first
it was top since the Dutch mark will
vanish but it was it is known for many
periods with excruciating precision
every 20 seconds you can have data in
this context which are data like one
never thought one could find in the
context of economics of Finance the data
act in physics in the best cases someone
measured when does the diagram and the
towel Q is the conventional name now for
the slopes of that thing
I don't want take time for that on the
right there is there is this envelope of
these lines and this envelope is called
f of alpha and these things are the the
the fundamental characteristics of of
the processes so to come back to to
these if one did the same analysis of
these on these eight you find the same
results again every analysis written
appropriate to find very different
results so here is the this matter of of
manichaean view of the world when I
describe to you in the beginning that
roughly smooth of course I have mind the
fact that that item that
even though smoothness is so rare in in
our experience it was a transformed into
geometry in the marvelous fashion and
now was myself as a young man totally
immersed in classical geometry the most
wonderful thing one could imagine and it
by by this kind of extraordinary miracle
it gave rise to a description of nature
beginning by ellipses being good for
teller for describing planets motion etc
etc the whole of science is dominated by
mathematics which is that was smooth and
that mathematics arose early on
derivatives of course are are part of it
very strongly and and most
differentiable manifolds and so on you
find his worth differentiable all the
time these are the primary objects of
mathematics and particular of Science in
gravitation and light but now we have
that decision that in some parts of
nature things don't fit in this mold at
all
so by this belated process process which
started with very high very very
abstract mathematics was trying to get
separate from physics again remember
these words of Cantor which I find
totally extraordinary that
mathematicians can feed themselves from
nature by trying to feed themselves from
nature they introduced these concepts
and they related related ideas which
were called mathematical monsters and
the like to Ankara was many making fun
of of Cantor and piano by saying that in
the past partitions were inventing new
shapes to help us understand nature but
today they invent new shapes just to
annoy me well it was the case and so the
the central point of actual geometry is
that actually a counter was just plain
dead wrong that these shapes were not
the way no invented is irrelevant
whether he knew of the correct the
various schemes are not as relevant
that this mathematics was actually
necessary to take the first step for
study of roughness and so that brings
too bad but again into in very strong
relief this question of averaging which
destroys randomness the classical
pattern was that of thermodynamics I
don't know what anybody teaches that any
longer or classical thermodynamics
randomness it exists and then there was
a statistical thermodynamics in which
energy was not a constant but was
fluctuating a little bit but so little
only the fine electronic measurements
could pick the thermal noise and that
was discovered only rather recently
namely about time I was born for
everybody that this is the finish of
recently but but then the phenomena we
deal here are not like that things don't
a result and so what I have developed
increasingly over the years gradually
but focused not very strongly is again a
view which I would love to give you
Morris to finish this talk of states of
randomness now in mechanics we all
reveal the laws of mechanics are unique
well forget about details for the
phenomena we're looking at it's all
classical mechanics Newton and so on
laws are unique however if you look at
the assembly of molecules it matters
very much whether the temperature and
pressure are such that the whole thing
is a liquid gas or a crystal or a solid
dozen we used to say it matters very
greatly so one does not begin by
starting everything I'd initial on first
look it's a gas I know which tools to
use it's liquid
I know it's tools to use even though
liquids are pretty horrible stuff and
solid I know which tools to use now in
randomness this was not at all
emphasized to emphasize that there is a
beautiful axiomatic
good for everybody but then once you go
to practice especially practice in the
physics and engineering and finance one
always looked for a phenomenon which
averages everything sort of averaged out
two limits very quickly
was neither rhombus after a certain time
but the phenomena which which I study
whether it is in nature and that means
turbulence or whatever or in culture
that is stock market or everywhere this
phenomena do not give any evidence of
being averaging I call them
I call them widely random and and the
the very simple formulas in the context
give very very very very complicated
structures I would like to end up by one
thing I said I was ending but let me
just add another point at one point I
was very much at actin by my friends
mostly my friends enemies did not even
bother because i describing an
alternative view of nature which was so
different from the view based on
smoothness smoothness in whose include
of course everything which is ruled by
partial differential equations Laplace
full hip was know that he stalks and
this thing had not the French not
derivatives had strange behavior and so
on so do these things belong to
different universes well I don't think
me do I think it's just very unified I
think that that partial differential
equations if pushed beyond the
conditions under which the stringent
conditions under which solutions are
unique and smooth and differentiable and
everything they give rise to very
complicated behavior and one example of
it is that we take a large assembly of
particles interacting by inverse square
root attraction a la Newton if you start
with Poisson distribution or just or
just the lattice and put some pinch of
energy to start it after a very short
time you see that these these particles
go because strongly complicate and
reassemble themselves into a fractal
universe
I didn't mention factory inverse until
now but I would like to see two words
about it
distribution of galaxies the universe is
factor there is no density all kinds of
things occur which are quite quite new
well that would suggest the fact that
the clustering of galaxies could very
well not be due to specific specific
complicate forces which we don't know
but the simple behavior of particles
under one of our square attraction and
so that rate equation is clustering up
there in the sky or is up there in the
head well it may well be in her head I
don't know but it's the question which
has been discussed in fact one when
finds that many of these questions
become very very much revised now from
begins to him to include the flat fan of
the universe oh yes it's a fact
early on which is sort of twenty years
ago when I wrote my book universe was
prospectively factor up to five
megaparsecs fifteen million light years
depth is nothing by universal standards
but then except to 20 to 50 to 100 I
don't know is between two and three
hundred for most people now and many
people believe it's one thousand which
belief our so if it is true that the
universe rational up to that level then
fractality
will insert itself into cosmology in a
very strong fashion therefore not only
fact early to be a result of very simple
laws of physics like Roswell was
possibly but effect understanding about
your limit Rosen
well I must stop here because since I'm
a cop more complicated become very
complicated and it's not for this
lecture I've been writing on this topic
for a long time as you see and also for
those scientists in finance the journal
quantity finance has several papers in
the current year on that I publish right
left that's my book on finance my book
on or noise I would have to end by this
one which is coming out in a few weeks
or a few days perhaps by frame myself
on mathematics education we find to our
utter amazement that humans like
fractals
so and I won't mention him at art but
this was a result of a very very very
poor programmers work he had some bug a
semicolon or something not dreadful it
gives the result he stopped apologizing
feeling to be filed
I started thinking from what on my heart
and before correcting the the the bug we
had his picture taken
it's something on the mandible said
mistake was made but it's a whole topic
unto itself that that humans seem to be
happy with roughness many you must have
say experience as I do because many that
you say I'm a petition of people say I
find mathematics utterly dry and dull
well I don't but they do but this is one
part of mathematics and that's mechanics
of the flat and the smooth the
mathematics of the Rafah has developed
by many people hundred years ago and now
now it's galloping development on all
sides never gets this reaction fantasy
if I had only done that in high school I
would have loved mathematics well you
don't need to be told that math next
lovable but it's M it's it's only at my
old age that I dare present my life and
the story of science as being a conflict
between two forces one the first good
and bad the evil you choose which one
which smooth and rough but I think it
has illuminated my view of how things
occurred and the reason why roughness
came so so late why so difficult is
because it simply is more difficult it
requires DIF mathematics which was
developed on a recently which developed
now for the purpose of this
investigation it requires just a
different viewpoint but
it is I think definitely a frontier of
scientific investigation thank you
Thank You professor mantle brought we
have time for a few questions we have
two microphones up here but you've
managed to fill in the density of the
auditorium sufficiently high that we may
have some trouble getting to them so if
you want to ask without the benefit of
amplification please speak out as well
as you can do we have any questions one
over here
[Music]
much more than you think and much more
than I thought not so not so long ago
and we have now for several years that
here in at Yale a workshop during summer
for high school teacher so we get the
cream of Connecticut so they are the
best but they tell us stories which are
quite incredible and they asks about how
electronic crime can bring it is your
high right time
some people say elementary school one of
our friends we have a kind of network of
friends around who have been using these
techniques and some of friends have
tried with the kindergarten children
they had they put them blocks the blocks
had o or I or X and still play with that
then you put other fractal things and
the challenge is to rebuild the fraction
by putting this in certain order the
case becomes so absorbed apparently that
they are lost in because that's the real
task it is not a task which did you that
teacher has imposed it tests that nature
has imposed on humanity for forever and
forever and so the in junior high is
very easy everybody who is anybody knows
how to work reform at eleven which put
me to shame because I never did learn to
program but so it it should be early in
a certain sense the question of whether
this is the right mathematics to begin
with is the wrong question because the
the mathematics was smooth had been so
elaborated I had become very very far
from experience and the questions it us
are so refined that it's that it is it
is not question which come naturally
the not questions about them about
anything on beam has thought the best
concern about the about the circles I
was a geometry not I love that but I was
the only one who loved it for all the
other it was artificial thing that
somebody mean Pascal just made to bother
them but question about about about
mastering roughness which after again
they rule and not the exception
smoothness is engineering
stable smooth well not quite supposed to
smooth because it's only several years
there so it has some roughness I'm sure
fracture but on an approximation smooth
it's engineering which scold which is
dry and cetera et cetera so so if
mathematics can kind can go back back to
its origins and it is not even something
which is artificial for example I mean
give an example while I'm discussing
that with a friend day I introduced a
notion which is which was taken as being
the end of madness that of negative
dimension now you measure things so I
measure roughness and now you can also
measure
vacuity emptiness so listen to that if
you take two lines in 300-page space
their intersection well they're not the
same intersect of course but
intersection of lines is less empty than
the exceptional line the point or of two
points that looks like science fiction
actually it's a question which arose
when friends of mine were looking at
intermittency of turbulence in the
laboratory because I could explain why
it's long story but then to explain it
we must understand that that lines are
not lines the lines a little tubes and
lines being little tubes is not only
invention of me estimation of minkovski
was very great man 1900 and who point
out that when this away from all kinds
of horrible paradoxes in mathematics by
never thinking of lines on lines or
surfaces surface but thinking of of
lines as being tube surface edenia
become fortresses realize cetera so the
when goes back to these things not only
when one goes back to mother earth to
get strength again but when does in the
fashion of fruitful because without this
element of going back into epsilon
neighborhoods to call him by a fancy
tail term one could not make sense out
negative dimension and negative
dimension is something you can measure
in which a useful thing in the study of
of turbulence we have another question
well certainly certainly short market
the human behavior as a matter of fact I
have come to use the word culture in the
sense which is perhaps not not smooth to
some some ears I speak the fractal
geometry of nature and then giving an
example like stock market but taken take
example of an internet it's human
behavior it's not exactly what you think
human behavior but large number of very
billion people working on cross purposes
and put this thing together and works
Marvel's most a time and every so often
it's terrible and your messages don't go
through but so people first tried to
apply to the internet the techniques
which had worked for for telephones that
was placed on West's own behavior and so
on it was absolutely off the mark it is
a multi-platform and it has to be
multi-platform now after the fact is
understood so here is the human behavior
and it was design of this design very
informal and noisy and messy design of
this huge system which for reasons which
are after the fact so the vaguely
understood is multifractal but you don't
have to understand it to live with it
because you have to live with it and so
if you if you make me equipment you
better test whether its properties will
be his well in the fact and face of it
but I'm trying I was try to to speak to
start with human behavior which is not
usually called as such but art is
certainly human behavior and so does art
have fractal aspects certainly and let
me give you an example of that which I
still find the mind-boggling my friend
my friend I should Russian had found
experimentally that that music is one of
ref noise like these things I was
showing you here he's a physicist and he
is not a loud person so it was sort of
didn't become very widely known but then
I was approached independently by two by
two composers one in New York and one in
Europe and you must know the names the
charles warren and george Ligety who
told me that looking at my pictures made
them understand nature of the craft and
as for each
and they said well I speaking in voice
of either because they exactly same same
explanation I have been trained in a
very classical conservatory traditions
and you very well about all the
instruments their values it's about
everything but I was not told one basic
thing which is what distinguishes a
music piece of music from a collection
of noises and I learned they said each
of them said by trial and error
I brought the composition to my teacher
said to busy and I brought another
composition it's not decorate enough and
another proposition it just goes up and
down too much doesn't go up but not too
much after a while I finally understood
what to do and I've been doing that very
well and I'm sure it in or Det and
worgen there are very famous people and
the pictures it's obvious it's obvious
except nobody told me that
but if a stone that is a sonata 21
Minister three movements Allegro lento
presto different each movement loud soft
very loud each so the thing must have
structured on scales something will be
changing at every scale and that's it if
you get that you get at least bad music
and bad music is much better noise and
everybody sing by music and voice was
telling a story about about dissipate
atonal music and Chinese say this bad
Korean music Korean bad Japanese music
Japanese bad time music whatever it but
was music of some barbarian race but so
that the essence is not at all
fundamental again wouldn't bad musical
together no sorry
I don't know unknown in painting so in
classical in the classical landscape a
very artificial form of art both in
oriental and European tradition so it
was big tree which framed it and then
this little man and so on all these this
rules of composition if you look at it
one big thing and most of the books of
art did speak of of design and I tell
you what I did discover
I do my own my own covers for my books
this channel well I like to do it so so
the this this book for teaching you has
every single cliche of proposition
because I felt it would be effective so
but on the other hand I was a look at
the film of Kandinsky painting all his
paintings it looked exactly like a
program of do fractals with joke she
would look at this piece of a thing and
then bung a big line solid line it's a
it's you see that inaudible
then.who small lines on the film ends
has small small small brush and he's
adding little things all over the place
so he puts big small and medium strong
elements of scale which is exactly the
kind of basic bottom motif like a
fatality I could go on forever and
forever so the fact that that is DISA
speaking of current behavior that but
but if you look at at at this African
village some this behaviors not not in
the sense of a physiologist but the
sense of the artist on the ground now
physiology system that's not imagined
now I'm many my friends tell me that
they have a nervous recording look like
these things I showed I be very much
interest in seeing them and but I know
very well that and if you describe some
some surfaces in the body that is
certainly a human behavior some surfaces
are meant to be as small as possible
given their volume and other as big as
possible the skin should be smooth and
out like a young child's skin and the
longer inside must be as confused as
complete as possible so the the two the
two criteria of design lead to either
smooth shapes or two extremely
convoluted shapes which happened to have
fractal fractal features the long for
human long for example is branching a
fractal on twenty three levels twenty
three levels is very healthy
bifurcations very healthy number it's a
million I think we're going to need to
wrap up right now but I'll invite all of
you who want to stage to come on down
and speak with Professor Mandelbrot for
a few minutes and I'd like to conclude
by thanking professor Lorentz for
joining us today and let's give
thanks to Professor model drug
[Applause]